good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
but I believe that entrepreneurs will
solve all of the world's major problems
so to help you on your journey today's
message is let go of the past over to
you Joel Osteen we all have had negative
things happen to us people did us wrong
the company laid us off a clerk was rude
to us it's easy to go through life
offended in self-pity
blaming others blaming ourselves even
blaming God because we're always looking
back we living the negative we end up
carrying around all this baggage that
weighs us down one of the best things we
can learn to do is drop it let it go
whether it happened 20 years ago or 20
minutes ago don't carry negative baggage
from yesterday into today you won't live
a victorious life if you're always we
living what didn't work out who hurts
you the mistakes you've made the reason
it's called the past is because it's
over it's done it's history now do your
part and let it go well Joel they've
betrayed me they walked away broke my
heart that's why I'm bitter that's why
I'm upset but they hurt you once don't
let them continue to hurt you by always
thinking about as long as you're
dwelling on that it's going to keep you
from the new things God wants to do the
story that you are telling yourself as
to why you can't be successful is
holding you back and will always hold
you back until you let go of it you'll
keep repeating the same pattern over and
over and over again and playing a small
game because that story you have in your
head just keep cycling continuously over
and over and over again as a quick
example I went to his Tony Robbins
seminar in LA and he did this
intervention with a woman and he was
asking her why she was depressed and all
she kept doing was talking about
and legitimately terrible things that
happened to her in her upbringing and
how she was abused and everything
happened in her family and just really
terrible things that you wouldn't wish
on any human being and what he did was
he just kicked quickly moving past each
one each one just moved past okay and
then and then and then not pain in a lot
of attention because what does that
person want to do she wants to stay
there
she's living this painful past over and
over and over and over again and is
letting to find who she is and what
she's going to do it's how she lives
every day because of that really painful
past and so by ignoring it and not
letting her stay there he was able to
transition her to say all these terrible
things that happen you can't change that
I feel terribly sorry for you that's a
nobody should have to go through that
what you're here now now you get to
decide all those terrible people are
gone they're not in your life anymore
you get to decide what happens now and
at some point we have to do this for
ourselves if your parents told you that
you'd never be successful or you know
the people around you and your teachers
or whoever it was you know at some point
you decide I'm going to be an adult I'm
in charge of my life I'm going to make
the shift for me it was I was always
worried about letting people down and
that's why I'm always early to meetings
and I always do what I say I'm going to
do and I would always kind of under
commit and over-deliver and a lot of
that is positive those are all positive
traits you wouldn't want the opposite
but it also meant that I would turn down
opportunities that were good for me and
good for other people because I was
afraid I wouldn't bring enough value
even though in my head I knew I could
bring value I was just afraid that I
couldn't bring value and I would wish
that meetings would be canceled or
people you know would say you don't show
up anymore and I still have bits of that
today but it's not debilitating I go out
and make those meetings happen and go
out and speak at those events and create
content for you guys even though that
little bit remains I'm able to move
forward and accomplish things that I
want to accomplish because as long as
you continue to live with a story that
has happened to you in the past
well as you say stuck there you're never
going to go off and do amazing things
you're never going to lost and achieve
your potential
so the question they today is I'm
curious what story from the past is
hurting you is keeping you where you are
it's preventing you from doing amazing
things let's share it up put it down the
comments below I'm really curious to
find out thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot events press
your approach to life and change through
your accurate experience yes well you
just get over you not live long enough
you can change and you don't you miss
what I you know go over you have to
change and I've realized over the years
I've got so many changes in my life and
change because that's the nature of life
and if you don't go with it amazed when
I really get into it again another we
leave in the books they just live all
the time
talk about something happens in thirty
Israel they're like zombies and I can't
hang out with those people I know I
can't spend more than five minutes with
me just I feel like suicide end because
I think it's so guilty about being happy
and I said well because it's a real like
suggestion so many years I thought like
this big rehearsal for the big event and
somebody in nonsense and said Tony this
is the big event life is in tension you
know we spend so much time thinking it's
a rehearsal for the big events the big
red carpet in the style our past is very
determinants when you think about Europe
or the Western Hemisphere in general we
are stuck by issues of the past it is
the past that holds back you know and if
you said that you were I've done in the
past you said let me burn everything let
me get rid of everything in the past you
you're free to start thinking about the
future but if you're still collecting
the past and looking to the past as a
solution having history is a very strong
anchor you're unable to move forward
because there are historical reasons why
our tribe of humanity is such a slow
changer because change is very very
scary and human beings don't do scary
things on their own they take something
much bigger to force them into change
what kind of big thing who desi for
every human being individual it's the
heart attack the car accident the
something that happened which was much
bigger than you which suddenly you wake
up and say oh my god I've been spending
all my life inside a box just working
for someone else oh isn't there a better
way for Humanity in general it is this
that suddenly it stops raining suddenly
everything goes crazy and you can't
control the climate so that's big enough
if the world were hit by a meteorite it
would be enough it takes enormous things
like that so we are a bit dinosaurs in
that sense that we will roam around and
do our thing until we're hit by
something much bigger than us and that's
true even for the individual who needs
the artefact to wake up to find out the
different working too much